Entschuldigung
Habt ihr eine Empfehlung wo man gut frühstücken gehen kann?
Weil Taco Bell ist ja schön und gut aber ziemlich ungesund - Ja, aber nicht zum Frühstück
Wissen Sie wie ich nach Hogwarts komme?
Ich denke nicht, dass Hogwarts in diesem Land ist
Nein, es gibt ein Fan Festival!
Danke! Ich versuche meinen Weg zu finden!!
Entschuldigung, kann ich ein Flasche Wasser haben?
Kein Problem, Mann!
Dankesehr - Du kannst auch zwei haben wenn du magst.
Ihr nutzt diese Autos nur um Güter und nicht Personen herumzufahren oder?
Nein, keine Leute.
Hi Leute! So ein schöner Tag, oder?
Ja!
Gefällt es euch hier?
Ich mag es hier, ich bin sehr froh hier zu sein!
Ist es euer erster Tag hier?
Wo bist du her?
Ich bin aus Los Angeles.
Oh nice! Also bist du den ganzen weg für das Event gekommen?